[Music]
I think I
had to go a little further to make sure.
[Music]
Elias was present with two men. His father was
giving medications, intravenous fluids, and applying
pressure on the patient’s chest in an attempt to revive him.
This process lasted about 35 to 40 minutes.
[Music]
Then I felt a feeling.  Inside me, there was something I was
looking for, so I started to open the beds and
remove the curtain from them. The first curtain that I pulled down was for
another martyr from Nablus. The second curtain that I pulled down
[applause] was a
state of denial. There was a state of denial in the emergency department. All the
medical teams were silent.
No one knows what to do. No one
knows.  What does he say
[music]